[Musique]
Ne riez pas de
rire
Non Je Ne regrette
rire ou
B qu'on m'a
fait ni mauvais
vante-moi bien
[Musique]
égal
Ne riez pas de
rire
Non Je Ne regrette
rien c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
FA
oublier Je Me fous du
[Musique]
J'ai passé avec m mois
souvenirs j'ai allumé le
mois du feu mois des chagrins
plaisirs Je n'ai Plus bisou
du balayeur
aimer avec la lumière
balayer trémolo pour
toujoursJe
[Musique]
réparation
Non de
rire
Non Je Ne regrette
rire ou
et bien, qu'on m'a
fait et ni le mal tout m bien
[Musique]
égal
Non r de
rire
Non je ne regrette pas
rire voiture maman
vendredi mois de voiture
jois aujourd'hui
commencer par
[Musique]
toi